gardez votre calme cet homme est sur le
point de vous agresser mais à l'issue de
cette vidéo vous serez quoi faire pour
le neutraliser un problème victimes de
tout blessures messieurs dames bienvenue
dans le four et répondent des swizzor un
peu moyen les gars qui frappent des
mannequins sur youtube à côté de moi
c'est des amateurs 1 chez vous vous êtes
avec un professionnel du self défense
les gens ont peur ils veulent se
défendre je vais redonner des objets
pour qu'il puisse se défendre
nous allons aujourd'hui testé des objets
de self défense je vais essayer tous ces
objets avec vous aujourd'hui on va les
tester en conditions réelles d'agression
ah oui je voulais pas présenté c'est
enzo enzo la 8 ans il adore fort nice il
prend la carte bleue de sa mère en
cachette pour s'acheter le pass de
combat régulièrement que les gens lui
parle il lui sert plus fort le trou et
une éthique comme ça et aujourd'hui il
s'est porté volontaire pour tester avec
nous les objets de cette défense
merci beaucoup et enzo tu ferais
attention tu as perdu tes lunettes
on commence avec le premier c'est une
ceinture pour mettre des savates
attendez j'ai un petit mot explicatif
ceinture avec boucle de poing américain
ils jouent les grands honneurs
elle permet de dissimuler le port du
poing américain et ainsi de surprendre
un adversaire qui ne pense pas être
désarmé mais les gars c'est quand même
triste de vivre avec une ceinture un peu
moche en te disant le jour commençait
comme ici ok les gars je vais retirer ma
ceinture à moi envoie une ceinture
normal franchement on agresse il ya des
gens qui avaient des mauvaises notes à
l'école ça leur a rappelé 2,3 souvenirs
là où regarder comme la ceinture et les
grands n'y a pas de trou là pour sceller
le premier trou il est ici et après la
main elle s'est donné que j'ai le
pantalon bas des fesses toute mon
enfance mais on va faire comme si elle
était un matériau qui met en condition
et toiles et ben moi deux mois tout en
argent sinon je n'échange l'individu
menace
je vais pouvoir déboucler ma ceinture en
toute discrétion sans que l'individu
leurs marques avant de lui mettre un
pain dans l'aisne est directement allé à
les jubilaires du sinaï puis je cherche
mon argent ça arrive les cartes format
je cherche mon argent je suis en train
toujours
qui n'a pas vu venir ah mais qui est
inventé ça tu as plus mal que
l'adversaire c'est horrible allez ça ira
pour cette fois gamin c'est vraiment de
la merde comme la violence soyez gentil
on vous attaque ne vous rabaissez pas à
riposter
laissez vous frappez je tenais à vous
messieurs dames nouvel objet enfin un
éventail blindés et il fait bien du vent
c'est incroyable à temps c'est quoi
l'histoire de cet objet parce que là je
veux savoir contraint de se défaire de
leurs sabres en se rendant à la cour du
seigneur les samouraïs japonais ont
développé le tessin jutsu ou l'art de
l'éventail de guerre sa part en
collection yoko directement je risque
d'être mais présent mais votre clientèle
c'est quoi la série samurai parce que je
comprends pas qu'elle utilise un
éventail en 2021 de manière régulière je
veux dire éditons éventail il est blindé
ou quoi que se tenait le mieux il a bien
l'air de l'est déjà pellinec donné un
jour maintenant et tu vas travailler à
l'école c'est comme ça qu'on influence
la nouvelle génération alors qu'est ce
que c'est que ça une épingle à cheveux
self défense
apparemment à l'époque les femmes pour
se défendre et utiliser le répandre
l'achat pour de grands départs pouvant
atteindre 25 cm et c'était la sixième
armée la plus utilisée par les femmes
mais c'est gros c'est glauque les pans
de la cheminée que l'héritière de
l'épinglé chapeau un nouvel accessoire
qui permet aux femmes de se défendre
avec les moyens du bord bah sinon donnez
leur un flingue
oui je suis un peu mauvais on conseille
pour se défendre ça c'est ce que j'ai
commandé il ya deux jours sur amazon
pour me défendre en cas de problème déjà
ça me donne chaud
à ta mère apparemment il conseille
d'utiliser ça avec un élastique et de la
patafix c'est super efficace le fouet
stinger a l'air de lui mais risation il
devient commun de se retrouver dans la
voiture d'un parfait inconnu pour se
défendre et mais vous aussi devenez
complètement parano et acheter des
objets inutiles qui ne vous serviront
jamais pour se défendre en cas
d'agression dans ce type d'habitat
cloclo ah c'est vrai que moi j'avais
j'avais je savais comment défendre n'est
pas dans un habitacle clos tu arrêtes le
fouet stinger est idéal le marteau en
alliage de haute dureté peuvent
facilement brisé une fenêtre tandis que
le faut et d'auto défense permet
d'assurer sa sécurité le temps de sortir
de la voiture
c'est vraiment cible s il ya un vrai
manque hubert what the fuck mais qu'est
ce que c'est que cette merde ça c'est
pour prêter une vitre et ça c'est du
câble d'antivol en fait les gars vous
êtes allé sur un chantier vous avait
chopé un peu les boues qui avait à
droite à gauche puis vous êtes dit ça
ferait une super arme de défense
lorsqu'on prend le taxi non arrête de
fumer d'immersion ça m'est revenu dessus
tamelaht c'est rudimentaire une poignée
un câble torsadé ça a l'air de faire
très mal hein ah ben là je vais rater
tiens tu as gagné c'est à ton tour
maintenant je décoche bon vous l'aurez
compris il est désormais impossible pour
vous de monter dans un hubert ou un taxi
sans cet objet merci le fouet stinger
allez les gars je crois j'ai déjà
l'objet de cinq défend sûrement essayer
de trouver vous avez quatre secondes
yanqui stinger a gagné c'est trop tard
la bague de celle des formes légères et
discrète à porter la bague de self
défense n'est pourtant pas l'outil idéal
pour dissuader ou se défendre lors d'une
agression at-on excusez moi ils sont
clairement en train de dire notre objet
est pas ouf
votre agresseur serait un peu surpris
jorna quel point il n'est pas au fait
l'objet que vous comptiez utilisée
contre lui donc vous aurez le temps
vraiment de fuir ou de trouver notre
stratégie telle grâce à un autre objet
que vous aurez acheté les glaces et une
bague et quand tu as pu quand tu appuies
sur le côté et une lame qui sort c'est
terrorisant
bonjour c'est papa d'enzo c'est entre
toi et moi maintenant
alors avant que vous me casser la tête
vis-à-vis de ce que j'ai fait à votre
fils j'aimerais signaler que vous avez
quelque chose dans votre chemise
voilà ça n'a rien à faire là plus large
est l'individu est pris de peur
il reconnaît cet objet il l'a vu sur de
nombreuses annonces instagram
sponsorisés surfant sur la peur
croissante des gens de se faire agresser
l'objet est très simple c'est une alarme
miniature elle aura pour effet
démobilisé l'adversaire
hossa match de fou c'est odieux
je suis choqué ça envoie plus de
décibels que moi quand je l'aï vu le
jeudi soir c'est vraiment un truc de ouf
mans si votre agresseur agents points
sur dix à chaque oreille mauvais gadgets
fallait plutôt acheté le pingers tuque
nouvel objet c'est une matraque lampe
alors je sais pas ce que ça fout là
c'est clairement un objet de gardiens de
musée
cet individu est là pour vous [ __ ] pas
de problème entre pop up
là il est aveugle et il sait plus où il
est est ce que c'est youtube est ce que
c'est witch est ce que c'est dailymotion
l'individu ne sais plus je peux ensuite
éteint à l'enpjj et à partir de là trois
secondes pour agir durant lesquels je
m'assurer que personne ne soit derrière
lui à se prendre le corps lorsqu'il
tombera dessus fin de l'agression la
matraque light c'est un objet qui vous
sauvera eau gelée vu passer celui-là le
magic stick self défense plus connu pour
son utilisation dans le domaine de la
magie le majestic se rapproche pourtant
beaucoup du bâton de kung fu shaolin
nommé l'ancêtre des armes
la particularité du majestic repose sur
sa taille qui permet de l'emprunter
facilement avec soin au ces adorables
regardez c'est adorable
commentcamarche faut tirer ça je suppose
mais dans quel sens à part juste pas me
le prendre dans la tête
[Musique]
ça alors
non mais frérot c'est une blague ou quoi
ton arme non je disais que je les kc je
voulais refaire l'ouverture c'est genre
c'est vraiment de chypre regardez c'est
du carton mec là il m'a massacré lui
déjà le combat commence j'ai perdu mon
arme des mains elle s'est envolée et en
plus elle est en carton mais si nul au
lait gaza ça c'est ouf je suis fan
absolu de klinsmann et ça les gars c'est
kingman il pleut j'ai une mauvaise
humeur je regarde un petit peu les gens
autour de moi dans l'air ma nation comme
ça gratos main sans m'en rendre compte
je viens de croiser le regard d'un
individu qui n'a absolument pas apprécié
ce qui vient de se passer
et regardez bien ce qui dépasse de son
bonnet la fameuse alarme l'individu peut
me neutraliser en un clin d'oeil le ton
monte entre les deux hommes
lorsque soudainement c'est terminé je
m'en sors inde m
avec seulement 30 ans de prison il y a
une épée dans le mange du pain mais où
est-ce qu'on est là où est-ce qu'on est
maman je vais avoir peur de tous les
mecs qui ont un parapluie c'est horrible
mesdames le rouge à lèvres non pas laser
mais le rouge à lèvres et ce n'est pas
une blague
ceci est vraiment un feu rouge à lèvres
capable d'électrocuter un parent je suis
très angoissé à l'idée de le manipuler
sachez le jeu vous le montre de plus
près ça fait vraiment la taille d'un
rouge à lèvres un peu plus fat
j'ai très très peur d'appuyer mec
[Musique]
ce bruit me terrifie je crois qu'un mec
qui se fait tasser devant moi je finis
plus dans le mal que lui
[Musique]
ok je m'excuse je m'excuse parce que là
j'ai mis de côté une partie des gens qui
regardent cette vidéo à savoir toutes
les personnes qui ne met pas de rouge à
lèvres rassurez vous le prochain objet
sera pour vous c'est ce téléphone c'est
un taser
c'est bon un faux téléphones qui
électrocute les gens j'avais peur je
veux pas manipuler ces trucs bon les
amis nour explique un objet je suis un
peu content je vous jure la violence ça
m'a fait vraiment j'aime vraiment pas ça
les trucs visant à blesser les gens et
tous j'ai vraiment du mal
d'un autre côté je pense c'est normal ne
pas être bien quand tu vois des trucs
qu'on était design et pour blesser ça
c'est le seul objet un peu premier degré
de la vidéo mais je pense qu'il a un peu
sauvé des gens aussi réellement il
s'appelle the guardian angels en gros
heureusement il s'est pas déclenchée la
pièce aurait aidé c'est un tout petit
objet en plastique qui est capable
d'envoyer du camp s'appelle du poivre
enfin le gaz là du gaz lacrymo à 4 m par
contre un essai faut bien viser tout
vous dire que si vous n'avez pas joué à
call of duty
bonne chance on va le tester mais avant
ça je vais aérer la pièce sinon je vous
retrouve est sacrément dans la main j'ai
très peur l'individu je le dis j'en peux
plus aider moi ça c'est clairement le
genre d'individu qui cache un poing
américain sous son bonnet nan mais sans
déconner et s'approche de le tient en
joue je lui dis je te tiens on joue mais
que j'ai peur je déteste ça j'ai peur
attention
[Musique]
au génie qu'est mon miroir j'ai envie de
garder les lunettes c'est psychologique
je me sens plus en sécurité
placebo il a fallu quinze minutes aérer
la pièce donc ce soir et ce pirate mais
je vous jure ça j'ai toussé instante
j'ai oublié
quoi qu'il en soit j'ai pas envie de
m'approcher trop de ce liquide horrible
ce que j'aime avec ça c'est que ça pique
et ou machin tu peux te défendre avec
mais t'as pas blessé ou défoncées le mec
pour autant j'ai passé le truc qui me
fait le moins bad et de tout ce qu'on a
testé je crois je crois que
l'épouvantail blindés me faisait plus
bon désormais vous saurez comment agir
en cas de problème en cas d'agression et
vous vous allez tout de suite vous
abonner activer la cloche c'est pas une
blague c'est pas une blague
je vais tout de suite jeté ces objets
avant de les confondre avec de vrais
téléphone cette formation gratuite
touche à ça j'en ai marre ah mais c'est
comme s'il y avait de la harissa partout
c'est horrible je vous dis à bientôt
j'espère que ces petites démonstrations
de france nous aurons plus attribués
dans une prochaine vidéo j'ai
l'impression que les squeeze hausse ne
se sont jamais aussi bien portés
[Musique]
c